Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Active Inference Lab.
Today it is August 20th, 2021,
and we are here in guestroom number
nine plate one with some awesome guests.
So we'll just start with introductions
and then head into a short
presentation
before a question and answer period.
So if you're watching live,
definitely write questions in the chat.
So I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher in California and Blue.
And Blue Knight.
I am an independent research
consultant in New Mexico,
and I'll pass it to Rafael.
Hi, everyone.
Thank you guys for having us over.
I'm Rafael
I'm also an independent researcher.
I have a day job at Google that has some
but not a lot to do with this topic.
And I been working with Brian of
and Jacob on this topic
for about a year and a half now.
It's been a wild ride.
So run outs go ahead.
And everyone.
Thank you. Daniel Blue.
The only thing that I'm up to this week
at Carnegie Mellon.
School of Business.
My areas of research, our collective
intelligence, better to come from reading
wasn't wanted in such a technical
architecture looking at,
but it is at adaptive systems
you know I was very interested
in the actor interesting book.
We met Rafael and Jacob met up,
you know, across
different CIA conferences
and got this project going.
So we're really excited to talk more
about and learn from all the discussions.
We have
always
sounds cool.
So let's go to Raphael's presentation
and then we'll just have
a bunch of time for questions,
so go for it.
All right.
Before I get started,
can you confirm this?
You can see in your right.
Yeah, we see the slides.
The slides. Perfect.
All right. Cool. All right. So
what are we doing here?
So as we mentioned,
the the interest here
is to try to understand
better the phenomenon
of collective intelligence.
And so two examples
here of what we're talking about,
and they're pretty different examples.
One of them is a pretty classic
example is the murmuration starlings.
So top left, I know the bird
that's solving a puzzle on the top,
right as a crow, not a starling.
So I'm cheating a little bit,
but that's fine.
So the on the bottom,
the example is the discovery of the Higgs
boson, which is an amazing example of
kind of a large scale,
long term sensitive collaboration.
So those are both legit
examples of collective intelligence.
And and yet the way that we approach
analyzing
these things is a little bit different.
So if you're doing something around
complex aerodynamic systems
or if the biology
you tend to look primarily
at the collective behavior
and to be able to do that in a computable
way, you assume that individual agents
are following simple rules to react
to the environment and to their peers.
And if you're doing something like
like anthropology or social science,
you're probably thinking of collectives
that look more like the bottom.
And so you're focused on
these really sophisticated agents
that have these complex
social cognitive capabilities
that are the thing, that analyze them
with the ability to focus collective.
And you try to build a picture
of the collective behavior
a kind of bottom up
from the sum of those interactions.
And both are valid perspectives,
of course, but they're speaking three
different languages, and we think that
there must a missing link here,
because if you think about us humans,
I mean, I definitely feel like
I am at the same time,
an autonomous and autonomous individual.
And a member of not just one,
but a bunch of collective right?
So I fluidly go in and out of companies
or sports team or, or
quality
and of course I'm part of my family.
So all these collectives can demonstrate
intelligence behavior that that cannot
be explained explicitly about aggregation
of all of the individual intelligence.
And yet
the collective itself
is a complex system
that is composed of components
that are in and of themselves, highly
autonomous, complex systems as well.
And that's how we framed the goal of our
of our research.
We're looking at
what we call the missing link, which is
a plausible theoretical description
of the functional relationship
between these two skills.
And in particular,
we think that the missing link
will be solid by understanding
what kinds of social cognitive features
enable the formation
of an effective collective within
within these kinds of autonomous
students.
All right.
To do that,
we've been using active inference
as as a framework
since the group here is probably way
familiar with active inference already.
I'm not going to go a lot into it,
just pointing out here
that we're approaching this.
You're might see the language
that's a little bit different
from from some of the canonical stuff
that for Semantic.
But Alex, we're using
some different domains later,
but it's really the same principle.
We're all looking at nature
and as a mark of blanket
and try to to model exactly what's
the generated distribution
that that creates behavior
in that in that sense.
And look at what happens
when you put it against some or
true system and dynamics that are
that are happening in the environment.
And of course you
you, you run the system as an
all right.
Except that in our case
it's a multi scale model, right?
Because we're interested
both in what happens at the scale
of individual agents
and the global system.
For us, it's actually quite interesting
to try to decouple things
and look at what's going on
very specific way.
Modeling many
to many relationships is really hard.
So we really focus on these pairwise
subsystems.
So our our motto is really composed
of a collection of pairs of agents.
They only interact with each other
within a single pair and
we basically compose them
the what we call the system scale model
bottom
up from copies of these pairs of agents.
All right.
So let's look first
at the individual scale, where we have
each pair is operating on the same
physical environment they're sharing.
Then think of them as sharing.
One of these circles,
if you're familiar with
with the McGregor model
that that's been published in 2015.
It's very simple, very simple.
Intentionally
stylized active inference
model that was originally designed
to be analytically solvable actually.
So it allows us to have a really clear
view of what's going on on this system
as a general system.
And we just added
some minimal capabilities.
So each of the agents that are marked out
as little can think of them
as little parts within this
within the circle environment,
they, each of them can only do a couple
of things, which is their capabilities.
They can only observe their own position.
They can't directly
observe the environment or that that is
meaning
they can't observe their own position.
They can only get a clue
which is an on off sensor
generated by a chemical signal on each.
So I'm getting a ping here from
a friendly viewer, also known as my wife,
saying that my image may be blurred
and now it's good father's
yes. It might look a little different,
but I have a high resolution,
one saved locally no matter what
the final process YouTube one looks like.
Thanks, YouTube
all right.
Thanks, YouTube.
All right. Cool.
So as as I was saying,
the main way that agents get information
about their physical environment
is by this sensory state,
which is a binary.
I want a on off sensor
that you can think of it
as being generated by a chemical signal
or a kind of smell on each cell.
And it's emanating from this
from this source for this same source
position.
So that's pretty much it
about the physical environment
and agents can go left
and right or states and so on.
That environment now
talking about the relationship between
between agents and their peers on a pair
there, Kiran,
there's a funny thing to say, but
the the agent can observe their
their peer or their partners
position, relative position
meaning I'm one or two or however many
to the left or to the right.
They can be actually
in the same position as well.
And they can also observe their
their moles.
Right.
They're there, can observe
whether the agent,
the other agent, the partner has gone
to left five or six on the left.
And the last
say, direction
right.
Let's talk a little bit about reward
functions.
The agents have independent report
functions that are to speak
with one common pick and one private.
That's the reason why that supports them.
Become clear a little bit later. Cool.
So that's it.
That's pretty much it about the individual agents and promises a really simple,
really simple model and the global scale.
They said is number of agent there
you can think of like 80 copies
of these two pairs of agents,
meaning 160 agents
in total or or whatever.
And from that perspective
of the higher scale, the
the markup blanket is actually composed
of the,
of the collections
of all of these pairs, right?
So they are each interaction
interacting with a
with a global environment.
And the cool thing is that we're square
the way that the sensor inputs
are relayed
to each agent is as designers.
So you can think of it at the top level
as kind of
bringing in some, some
not just some target states that are
that are pretty much the sort of smells
that that agent picks up
all right.
The other important thing
is that the optimal state for the system
corresponds to the agents
share target only.
But so from the system's perspective,
it wants all the agents to be
in that share target.
But the agents themselves,
they don't know it.
Why it's important is that it means that
there is no exogenous incentive
to achieve the global goal.
So it's not like just for nudging.
We're asking all of the agents
the same thing.
And lo and behold, they're going to do it
all right.
And let's talk a little bit about
how free energy minimization happens here
on the on the individual level
and the level of the individual agent.
We just assume that there's some process,
some neurological process
within each agent
that that does gradient descent.
That's the traditional technique.
But at the
global level, what we're actually doing
is that the behavior
that we're simulating at the collective
of all of these individual agents, the
the aggregate of that behavior
is what we want
what we would like to see
approximate gradient descent.
So that's the thing that we do
actually want to demonstrate here.
We want to look at the behavior
of the collective
calculate the free energy, the collective
free energy, which is F Sigma here
in this in this equation at the bottom,
and see if it's actually minimized.
If it's minimized that way,
then we can say that the system this this
group of very simple agents
as a collective, it's
performing active influence
at the global scale or not
and shock reveal
what we find is that the extent
to which the collective
is actually able to do that
if the energy to be assumption depends
on the social capabilities
that we and now these simple
so we focused on two
cognitive capabilities or or features
that are stylized versions of
of things that we traditionally look at.
And in social science
the first one is
what we call theory of mind
and what we define that as that
is the ability of an agent
to put itself in the shoes of another.
And we actually try to model
that in a free literally.
So if you think of shallow versus deep
representations of of the other,
you can think of a shallow representation
as like a mechanistic
or if they're going this way, it means it
means there's some rule based
kind of kind of move kind of way,
which you, you could think of, of being
an internalization of a rule that I think
somebody else is following up
but we actually did
here is something quite different, right?
So it was based on the philosophy
of active inference. That
means that
the agent has every
agent has self-actualization.
And what we said is, hey,
the socialization
of the internal part of it needs to be
implemented by some kind of quote
unquote neural neurological circuits.
And what if that's exactly the same type
of circuit, the same structure
we're being used to model the partners.
So, so that you actually
also had a partner actualization.
So this is quite literally
putting yourself in the shoes of
of your partner, right?
So you have your own beliefs
about your position
and about your desires and you also have
the literally the same kind of belief
about the partners position
and their desires and you can use that
loss of force, whatever, sorry,
you have it over from which you have from
the environment to predict
the partner's actions
exactly the same way that you're
predicting your own actions.
The only difference, of course, is that
you don't actually control your partner.
So you're predicting that
that's the dotted line from it to out
or from we want to be in the right.
So your predicting
or how you're creating counterfactuals
about what your partner's going to do.
And then of course, you can observe
observe whether or not prediction
matches the,
the, the outcome in the next round.
And that's each partner
is asked to calibrate their model of the,
of the, of their partner.
And the other thing is you want
those two predictions to be consistent
between themselves, right?
You want that
you want the beliefs about yourself
and the partner to have some consistency
and that actually helps you
to what you call triangulation.
Right? So, you know,
very maybe very
little about your physical environment,
but you're seeing your partner
do stuff and
moving around
and you're using that information
to inform your
your belief about your own position.
So that's the power really.
The power of all theory
in mind for our model.
And we're going to see how useful
that is.
Now, the other
one is goal alignment
I realized that I've been speaking
for a long time,
so I'm going to go a little bit faster.
And so the other feature
that we talked about
is this thing called goal alignment.
And it's really about the ability
for an agent
to adapt its goals
to to match another goal.
And this is
this is a bottom up
incentive and sensitization mechanism.
Remember that what I mentioned
that the system actually has an optimum
but has no direct way
to tell the agents about it.
So the assumption here
is that to the extent that you can,
that you have overlaps
between the two agents goals,
and it turns out that
those that the overlapping goals
are aligned with a system optimum
that provides a bottom up way for
for collectively optimal behavior
to to to happen.
And we didn't model dynamics,
the dynamics of how that goal
alignment happens.
We just assume that
it can be flipped on and off
just again for simplicity.
And that's that's the thing
that we'd like to explore for the call.
So we did a virtual experiment.
We ran simulations
with all four possible combinations of
with or without the right mind,
with or without goal alignment.
And so and basically what we
and the baseline here,
which is without the remote with alcohol,
make a response to the scenario
where these agents
are pretty much blind to each other.
They're not interacting with them
with each other at all.
We can see each other,
but they're not using that information.
And we're going to see how those features
actually drive
the behavior of individual agents
and also the system itself,
of course.
So basically what we find is that
I don't think I mentioned this before,
but we defined in each pair
that there is a strong,
perceptually strong and perceptual agent.
The retention is pretty much following
almost a random noise
that they have very, very poor smell
receptors,
but they
still they can still use the partners
position motion to translate. Right.
So the the effect here that we see
agents wise are mostly what benefit that
these social capabilities
and the weak agent with.
And so we see that
the model with both together
actually is the one where
the performance of those
the weak agents consistently improves
really well to the point where it gets
almost as good at finding an optimum
as the as the strong agent.
And why is that so the key
to the basic intuition is that theory
of mind by itself in this model
is not able to improve outcomes.
Not that much because
remember, each agent has 22 goals
which correspond to the two peaks here
and in the middle drawing the left side.
And because there's this great ambiguity,
right,
if I'm going to to assert in a certain
direction what goal that
it's hard to interpret that
in terms of going to the specific goal
if you don't
if there's two possible goals
for your thought.
So that limits
how much useful information
the agent can get from the
from the strong
and goal alignment itself
doesn't help by itself because now
you have a small reward target.
Target but they're so notch for well
defined where we're going.
But putting that the ticket values
together actually does result in.
Interesting.
So I'll I'll let it let that sink in
for a second.
A theory of mind knowing for
putting yourself in the shoes of another
plus having goal alignment
the capacity to to to share a goal
it actually creates
benefits
for the agents that are compensates
helps a lot to compensate
for deficiencies in the in the
in the agent's ability to navigate to
and that
also is true looking at the collective.
So remember we're talking about
whether these models
can minimize
the collective free energy F sigma.
So we're interpreting this these runs of
all these fronts are optimization
for the individual agents
as part of one single Bayesian inference,
step four, do you collect them?
Right.
And what you see here is the
if we're doing this right,
the graph should look like
like gradient descent down the
the free energy gradient.
And this only really happens
consistently towards a fifth out of zero
in the fourth model where you have
both of these social capabilities.
As we mentioned,
you get some improvement.
You have some abilities from these agents
that are coming
from their individual capabilities.
But when you when you put
the social cognitive together
with with the capabilities
about the environment,
that's when you get the ability
to really minimize the system, manage
all right.
So that's what what we found in our paper
and we think it's a pretty interesting
and compelling example
of being able to link
so in a very stylized way,
but very clearly linked
social cognitive capabilities
at the individual level that are just
that are not just simple rules. Right.
With this
not about simple rule following,
but it actually has to do with
interpreting the other
and using that information
and linking that directly to
to active inference
at the collective level.
And what would like to say that?
I think the four most exciting things
that we've been discussing
the last couple of months are,
first of all, can you actually
look at experiments with with humans and
because,
you know, these capabilities, it's
got these social capabilities
are things that you can measure
your mind and abilities
and goals of things that you can test out
with human subjects.
And can you use our model to to
to represent and simulate
and contrast
with what happens in groups of humans
and see if the differences
in their abilities to
to to have theory of mind
and to align on goals
matches up with with what we're
defining here as energy minimization.
That's 11 idea.
Another one is, you know, collectives,
one of the things that collectives
can can have is behaviors
around shared resources.
And these resources involve them
with capabilities in different ways.
So that creates we think that creates
sort of an onramp to understanding
the idea of economic value
that's we've been joking jokingly
holding it for some omics.
This is the further down
you go, the more speculative we get.
But we think that
active inference can actually help us
understand
this notion of of
where does it come from?
Is it really just up
related to Star City
or is actually also related to
to the capabilities
that it's knowing with different agents
how these two things
relate to each other.
So we think that there's a
there's a powerful idea there,
this notion of, again, omics,
I wrote a little bit about that.
I think it's it's been starting
to pick up steam in some areas.
And, you know, ultimately
all of us are embedded in one
big collective,
which is guy from guy theory.
It's the planetary scale
collective intelligence
that sometimes works really well.
Sometimes it doesn't work really well.
Can we use these
sorts of ideas of multi scale
active inference modeling
to, to improve how we define and model
the the behavior of that guy assistant
finally going from the pretty big
to the pretty small and individuals
and individual humans brain
we've been looking Jeff Hawkins since
the thousand in theory
from his recent book
and there's a lot of interesting ideas
that look a lot like active inference but
as far as you know nobody's
tried to model with what he says
is the fundamental unit of intelligence
which are these vertical columns
in the New York cortex
nobody's tried to model
those using active inference
and that's name implies the
the main thesis of of this theory
is that the intelligence in our brains
comes from the collective behavior
of all these
all these cortical columns
interacting by a certain algorithm.
And so what it would look what would it
look like to try to implement this
this unit
so of the brain, what inter, quote
unquote agent capabilities are required.
So I'm going to pause there.
I've I've overstayed my welcome
oh, I'm really curious to hear
what kind of questions
or thoughts we have in homes.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Awesome.
Thanks for the fascinating unit then.
Thanks.
So great presentation.
So maybe we could start
with just a preview of a then blue.
Just what is bringing you
to being right here
and what are your first thoughts?
Either being involved on the work
or on the collective behavior side
more generally.
Of blue?
Are you being pushed out?
You've got a lot of authors.
Thank you.
Know, I think all this work in particular
and I'd start with this work
as a context or up the
the the bigger idea is
a part of the thing that we
I'm invested and invested together
is figuring out one
understanding causality
of where does collective intelligence
emerge from, what are the interactions
between humans or humans and machines.
Those things
while you can have causal theory from
a management social science perspective,
it's very
hard to know that it is optimal.
Is that the outcome lack of statistical,
you know, mechanics approach
to looking at best behavior
and saying that
the at the aggregate level,
this is how the outcome should behave.
But you can look at the micro
interactions underneath.
So think from my perspective, active
inference is
not not correct,
but from a social scientist perspective,
it is an atypical way of physics, way
of looking at DeMarco,
looking at the statistical mechanics
without worrying about how exactly does
theory of mind come about.
So as Rafal explained,
we had a partner actualization group.
We think the analog in social science
is theory of mind.
And what we could demonstrate
is that even if there are individual
active inference agents, they will need
some form of partner actualization.
And in humans you can observe that
as the capability of mind
to be able to use each other
as sources of information.
So if I cannot
work in my environment
because my physical skills
like looking at and smelling the
different chemicals at different
levels is low,
but my social receptiveness is
so I can look at my partner and infer
something about my environment, then
I could still work in the environment
but that alone is not enough
for us to work as a collective.
Does the free energy
we collectively not go down
just if everybody can understand
each other's perspective,
what's happening, each other's shoes?
So then we need something more.
So the second thing that we introduce
and test out
is some form of aligning goals.
Like there has to be a reason
to find common peaks.
OK, the current model
does not see how it comes about.
That is a social science textbook
pushing the causality
like we trust each other
do we have a good communication
processes are not like that would be
accuracies and efficiency issues
in communication them since
all of this is not you know
yes doesn't worry about that.
But it tells us that
these two capabilities at the individual
level are important to get a collective
like I think from from our perspective
that is really the core contribution.
If you are saying that there are some
cognitive capabilities
that are beyond an individual EFA model,
the way MacGregor had set it up,
there are needed for it
to scale up as a collective
right there's much more to be done, but
we are starting to build these barriers.
So the exciting thing that I find that
more about what can be map,
which is experiment
if we run human agents
in a similar environment
and ask them to do a similar task
and we have agents working together,
can we create a mapping of
what is the theory of mind
index like the score for this person
or this person on this scale?
Because that would help us preemptively
say that
if you have a collection of people
that this distribution of theory of mind
and their ability to understand
each other like social perceptiveness,
which is standard scale
in social sciences, I think it's called
automating the mind in the AI,
that's a standard scale.
So if we can create a mapping
from a real indicator of theory of mind
onto these things, we can start having
some predictions that this team is likely
to succeed
more than this combination of so.
So that starts to open up data.
All right.
Now, we have some interesting
understanding
of how the whole system works
and can we try to
so this is very much the beginnings
of a grander research statement
and the research direction
that we are trying to pursue and using.
If in tandem with quantum theories
or management or social science theories
to figure out more,
how can we help things
better, design deeper
than that?
Is that enough?
Like, I didn't go much beyond that.
We're very happy to talk more on
other kinds with lots of level of people.
Audio.
Thanks for all. That was great.
Yeah, I really enjoyed this paper from
my background is like biological sciences
and so like I've done
cellular and molecular neuroscience
like all the way through my PhD
until I kind of
took the jump off the that.
So for
me it's I'm not as
well versed in the social science aspect,
but I think a lot about collectives
and I'm super drawn to collective
intelligence and even hierarchical
systemic organization, right?
So how bodies are different
from molecules
to cells to tissues
and organs, et cetera, and even like
societies and ecosystems, like the theory
that you were talking about earlier.
So so this picture was awesome for me.
I do have quite a bit of questions,
especially at like
the social science front.
Like in the beginning of the paper,
you guys outlines
like a whole lot of different
potential ways that we operate.
Like as multisystem
multi-agent systems.
And so like a lot of them,
you have theory of mind in there
and also the bow alignment.
But you also have like shared norms
and folk psychology.
And so what, what made you choose
just those two
as opposed to like testing
all the other ones out?
Or did you try others
or did you not figure out a way
to like mathematically get it together?
Or what was your logic there?
Experience
of doing?
I that
yes, I think so.
We had
about six months of discussion of
what would be a scoop of the paper
and that's where we got so many things
that guys are going to
get all really excited about.
Looking at a regular question,
what makes up the level of dynamics?
But before we could jump on
to any of those things,
I think it was important to boil down
as to what are the key
pieces that are needed
before we conclude.
So the key piece was at this point,
if does a very good job of explaining
an individual interacting
with an environment and how it operates.
So yes, we can go to norms,
yes we can go to these things,
but these are details
about how norms emerge.
And at the end of the day,
I'll get I could be misunderstanding
some pieces of it
because I'm coming from social scientists
to actual threats.
So pardon my errors.
That is correct me, my understanding.